c'est l'une des dernières prises de
l'armée russe dans le dombass la ville
de suite claude arsc bombardé en
permanence certains quartiers ont été
quasiment rayés de la carte la brigade
ukrainienne qui était stationnée a battu
en retraite les russes ont hissé leur
drapeau sur le bâtiment du conseil
municipal
un sort que craignent les habitants de
cramât torse qu à 60 kilomètres de là
comme cet adolescent qui observe les
décombres impuissant
je me suis habitué aux bombardements
dans la ville ça c'est un beau but de
122 mm depuis plusieurs jours volodymyr
zelensky se montre très inquiète face à
l'avancée russe
les forces armées ukrainiennes nos
services de renseignements et ceux qui
défendent le pays résistait une
offensive extrêmement féroce à l'est par
endroits lénine est considérablement
supérieure en équipements et en nombre
de solutions soldate c'est notamment le
cas à ces verrou donetsk où l'armée
russe concentre ses efforts la prise
serait importante c'est l'une des
dernières grandes villes de la région
encore sous contrôle des forces du
craignait la plupart des 100000
habitants fuient ce qui reste craignent
d'être encerclés et de subir un siège
comme un mario paul
[Musique]